cross-origin resource sharing or cores
is a mechanism that allows a website on
one url to request data from a different
url
and it's frustrated both front-end and
back-end developers since the dawn of
time you may have tried to use an image
on your website that lives on a
different url
only to end up with a broken image or
your website might try to fetch data
from your api
then fail with a coors error in the
console that happens
because the browser implements the same
origin policy as part of its security
model which allows a website to freely
request
images and data from its own url but
blocks anything from an external url
unless certain conditions are met when
the browser makes a request
it adds an origin header to the request
message if that request goes to a server
on the same origin
then it's allowed by the browser with no
questions asked however
if that request goes to a different url
then it's known as a cross origin
request
when sending the response the server
will add the access control allow origin
header
its value needs to match the origin
header on the request
or it can be a wild card which allows
any url to make the request
if it's a mismatch though the browser
will prevent the response data from
being shared with the client
this results in an error in the browser
but for security reasons there's very
limited information about what actually
went wrong
the solution to a corsair lies on the
server if you don't control the server
you're out of luck
if you do control it you likely just
need to configure it to respond with a
proper header in express.js for example
that can be achieved with a single line
of middleware code which tells the
server to include the course headers on
every response
now certain http requests like put or
any request with a non-standard header
will need to be preflighted
and just like at the airport it's a
sanity check that ensures the passenger
or request
is safe to fly on the airplane or server
the browser automatically knows when to
preflight and will first make a request
using the options http verb
the server will then respond saying yes
i allow this origin
to make requests with the following
methods at which point the main request
can happen
without fear of disaster that may sound
inefficient but the server can respond
with a max age header allowing the
browser to cache a preflight for a
certain amount of time
if you happen to be facing a coors error
right now open the network tab in the
browser
find the response and look for the
access control allow origin header if it
doesn't exist you need to enable cores
on your server
if it does exist the url may be a
mismatch with the website
or if it was preflighted it may not be
allowing those methods or headers in the
request
all of which are things you can
configure on the server this has been
cross origin resource sharing in 100
seconds thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one